le projet nemo une usine de production
d'énergie à partir des différences de
température de l'eau de mer le projet au
large de casse pilote et le maire de
castries la tête avec nouveaux ouvrages
plaisir
bonjour monsieur vialleton expliquez
nous pourquoi vous êtes contre ce projet
pourtant ambitieux innovant qui ferait
de la martinique véritable laboratoire
mondial dans ce secteur
bien égoutter oui ça aurait été
formidable
si nous n'avions pas devant quinze
pilotes devant bellefontaine et au large
de la martinique ce qu'on appelle un
établissement ce réseau seuil haut
ça c'est le plus grave de tous les
seuils ce bisou et il est dit que ce
sont des deux que dos il ya de ces quand
l'installation à des substances telles
qu'ils engendrent des dangers
particulièrement important pour la
sécurité et la santé des populations
voisines et pour l'environnement
on va reparler on va rappeler le
principe répond plaisir une plate forme
en mer qui pompe l'eau de mer vers la
surface la différence de température de
cette eau avec la surface et transformé
en énergie grâce à de l'ammoniac à peu
près 200 tonnes d'ammoniac la suite
l'énergie rapatriés sur la terre ferme
par câble
on va rappeler d'autres chiffres auront
peut-être voir d'autres points qui
fâchent 450 millions d'euros pour une
production de 16 mégawatts et le jeu
n'en vaut pas la chandelle selon vous
non parce que vous allez produire 16
mégawatts dont 5 mégawatts vont servir à
faire fonctionner le système vous allez
mettre sur le réseau 9 mégawatts
chaque mégawatt beaucoup de 50 millions
d'euros et quand vous comparez avec par
exemple de l'éolienne pour par mégawatts
d'éoliennes de grands wierre qui coûte
cher exceptionnellement cause de la
distance notre le point de production et
le branchement sur le réseau
ça coûte trois millions sept cent
cinquante mille euros par mégawatt ce
qui est très cher à prévoir et alaa au
prix normal habituel ci avait pas eu
cette distance donc là vous êtes à 50
millions et de quantité du solaire ça
coûte un million cent mille euros et ce
serait pour alimenter 15000 un ménage
alors et font plaisir
on comprend bien ce tollé de votre côté
vous tenter de mobiliser les autres
maires de la côte caraïbe oui monsieur
opposé à ce projet qui a commencé à être
financés par l'union européenne mathieu
gueuleton tendez soyons allons bout des
choses
nous allons mettre de l'ammoniaque qui
va 450 tonnes d'ammoniac si il ya une
fuite ça remonte en montant il ya une
partie qui reste dans l'eau ça devient
de l'ammoniac qu eux ackles ça tue ça tu
si ça monte ça sort en gaz et que le
vent souffle et que ça va dans votre
visage ça brûle les yeux ça brûle les
poumons
ça tue en plus vous ne pourrez pas
circuler à plus de 500 personnes dans un
rayon de 3 km 800 oeuvres tour de
martinique des yoles rondes
oui parce que le tour des yoles devra
passer à 7 km 600 de la cote pour
pouvoir parce que il peut pas y avoir
plus de 500 personnes en même temps dans
ce rayon il faut sanctuariser le secteur
à ce moment là mais oui et on vous ne
pourrez plus rien faire dans le coin et
même le long de la côte
nous ne pouvons plus envisager de projet
c'est fini qu'attendez-vous des maires
des maires voisins des mers croisées de
caisse pilotes
je n'attend pas des merveilles 1
j'attends de toutes les martiniquaises
et de tous les martiniquais de tous les
maires
2 jeudi soir 6h30 à case-pilote je
réunis j'invite les maires je ne vais
pas les citer pour ceux qui m'ont déjà
dit qu'ils viendront pas parcque aux
actions vis-à-vis d'eux mais j'en ai
déjà beaucoup qui m'ont dit qu'ils
viennent parce qu'ils sont conscients
nous avons le chlordécone
nous avons les algues tout ça sur la
côte atlantique et maintenant nous
allons mettre sur la côte caraïbe une
autre forme de chlordécone
nous mettons de l'ammoniac le long de la
côte caraïbe aggressively la martinique
est entouré on est dans qu'est ce qu'on
fait partout autour de la martinique ce
seront des dangers pour les
martiniquaises et martiniquaise vraie
conclusion se souvient quand même que
vous étiez partie prenante dans un
projet de gazoduc eux ramené du gaz de
trinidad à la martinique par des tuyaux
soumaré aussitôt annoncé sur les ondes
cette émission de ce matin 11 à 10 mai
en fait certains internautes ont dit
mais c'est un projet concurrent aux
siens c'est pour ça qu'il y oppose à
jamais de la vie
ça n'a rien à voir parce que le gaz
c'est pour aller alimenter une usine qui
fonctionne pour que au lieu de brûler du
gas-oil on brûle du gaz ce qui est moins
nocif mais le projet nemo ne donc le tm
en mer n'empêche jab nullement à un
gazoduc d'arriver là ça n'a rien à voir
est-ce que est-ce que le côté
expérimental qui ferait que toute la
communauté scientifique regarderai cette
petite île de la martinique avec ce
projet ne vous séduit par quelques pas
formidable tout couillon s'est maintenue
guerrier nous sommes les crétel la terre
le seul endroit sur toute la planète
terre où il y aura sauvé ou dans la mer
c'est à la martinique
donc effectivement ils vont nous
regarder et ils vont dire ben ses
boucles assure vraiment des crétins on
vient chez à la martinique ce sont des
kobe se sont fait expérience chez eux
alors il y en a qui se battent
aujourd'hui pour qu'on ne mette pas des
animaux dans des cages en
expérimentation pour ne pas les faire
souffrir il y en a qui se battent à
juste titre parce que on a des attitudes
vraiment déplorable avec des animaux
qu'on tue mais à la martinique c'est
formidable c'est bon nous sommes tous
des couillons envoyons envoyons la merde
pour la banque td québec monsieur moi je
ne suis pas d'accord tant que je pourrai
parler je serais contre ce projet parce
que je défends ma santé celle des
martiniquaises et des martiniquais
c'est pour ça que j'ai été élu bref vous
plaisir une dernière une toute dernière
question cela pourrait créer des emplois
également à peine quinze emplois
monsieur à peine quinze emplois alors ne
rigolons pas ça c'est à ramener des
textes communes de dinan et ça peut pas
mener de taxer dans la mer monsieur si
c'était sur la terre ce serait des taxes
baissé dans la mer donc la commune ne va
pas toucher personne ne va toucher c'est
un scandale monsieur avec cet argent là
vous pouvez couvrir toutes les surfaces
qui sont possibles d'être couverte les
bâtiments en énergie solaire sur toute
la martinique alors ça c'est un scandale
c'est le vol de la santé des
martiniquaises et les martin guerre et
c'est prendre les gens ici sont vraiment
ceux qui ne sont pas des crêtets venait
tout tête ou ça casse pilotes on a vu
jeudi soir toute la martinique venez
merci que cette affaire s'arrête dit
merci répond plaisir merde qu'est ce
pilote sur la route excusez mon retard
cheville interposés n'ai voté à jules
merci merci bonne journée
[Musique]